-Thank you!
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
Big night.
Big night for our show.
It's so exciting today.
Halloween's almost here.
I'm in a great mood.
All the decorations
around New York City.
Do you see it today?
It's beautiful.
There's skeletons
on Fifth Avenue.
There's spider webs by the
Empire State Building today.
I saw a giant pumpkin outside
the Manhattan courthouse.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Right outside the courthouse.
-Right there.
-Well, this is exciting.
After the success
of Taylor Swift's concert movie,
BTS announced
that next month
they are releasing
a concert movie on Amazon.
-Ooh.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-And if you thought
BTS was big before,
wait until you hear that Suga
is dating Donna Kelce.
[ Laughter ]
You heard it here first.
Some more entertainment news --
apparently, Kris Jenner wants
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle
to appear on an upcoming episode
of "The Kardashians."
[ Laughter ]
That's great -- Britain's
royal family meeting ours.
I mean, it's just kind of...
[ Laughter ]
I think they might be into it
because they just changed
their names to Prince Karry
and Keghan Karkle.
[ Laughter ]
How does that work?
-Come on.
-[ Laughs ]
How does that work?
Some political news --
Guys, Republicans
aren't any closer
to choosing
a speaker of the House.
Yesterday, they voted
on Jim Jordan,
and then, today, they tried
to elect Jim Jordan again,
but he lost by
even more votes.
[ Laughter ]
That's like retaking the SAT
and finding out
you got dumber somehow.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the House held a second
vote for speaker,
but once again,
no one was elected.
It's been such a long process,
and several members of the House
are speaking out about
the situation.
For example, first up,
Congressman Jim McGovern said...
[ Laughter ]
And Congressman Hal Rogers
said...
[ Laughter ]
And Congressman
Brad Sherman said...
And Congressman Mike Rogers
said...
[ Laughter ]
Congressman Alex Mooney said...
Then Congresswoman
Chellie Pingree said...
And Congressman
Donald Payne Jr. said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Congressman
Jorge Santos said...
And Congressman
Richard Neal said...
And finally, Congressman
Jim McGovern said...
So they're getting it done.
They're getting it done somehow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They'll figure it out.
Guys, well, listen to this.
I read that Amazon has started
delivering prescription
medications by drone.
-Mm.
-Now, you know this is because
Jeff Bezos is too embarrassed
to go into a pharmacy
for his Viagra.
That's what it is.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
Guys, Disney is celebrating
its 100th anniversary.
Yeah, 100 years.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's so many great
Disney characters
that I don't even know
if I could name
or even pronounce all of them.
-That's not a problem for me.
I know how to pronounce
every Disney character's name.
-I'm sorry, Higgins.
You know how to pronounce
the name
of every Disney character?
-Uh, yeah.
I'm an announcer.
It's my job to know
how to pronounce these things.
Go ahead, test me.
Give me some names.
-I'll show you a photo,
and you can tell me the name.
-Yeah.
-All right. I guess I can
test you real quick.
Who's this?
-Easy. Wendy's.
[ Laughter ]
-Close.
Uh, who's this?
-Lululemon.
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
Give me some hard --
Rapid-fire me.
Come on.
-Okay. All right, all right.
Here we go. Who's this?
-Baloney.
Chaka Khan.
Chips and Dip.
Jimmy Kimmel.
[ Laughter ]
Your mama's ugly.
Just Got Rabies.
Lawsuit and the Trump.
[ Laughter ]
Mos Def and 50 Cent.
Cocaine.
Sure, I Cried
During "Notting Hill."
Life's a Bitch.
Areola.
Miralax.
Harry Grandmother.
Herpes Cream.
Flomax Helps Your Jet Stream.
Oh.
Anus Taser.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, Kinky Sex With Jon Hamm.
Oh, come on, that's easy.
That's Taylor and Travis.
-All right.
Close enough.
Close enough. Thank you.
Steve Higgins, everybody.
That was close enough.
Very sorry.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sorry. You can do it.
I'm sorry I doubted you.
Guys, I saw that New York just
passed a new law allowing liquor
to be sold at 10:00 a.m.
on Sundays instead of noon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
New Yorkers were like, "No need.
The Jets are doing
better than we thought."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-10:00 a.m.
So now, on Sundays,
you have two choices --
bottomless brunch
or rock-bottomless brunch.
[ Laughter ]
I heard about a mother
in California who says
that she might have the world's
youngest talking baby after her
6-week- old daughter said,
"Hello."
-Mm.
-When reporters called
to verify the claim,
the baby answered the phone
like, [ Coarse voice ]
"Cheryl, it's for you."
[ Laughter ]